and now a follow-up to last night's
angle about the dismantling of our
military capabilities
to be a superpower the united states
needs the following number one a strong
industrial base so that we aren't
dependent on our adversaries for vital
items like computer chips
number two
a patriotic culture so that talented
young americans will be willing to
commit themselves to the country's
defense
number three
a functional military that'd be nice
with officers who know how to train
young people to fight and win wars
which brings me to point number four
generals and admirals who are capable of
developing and implementing strategies
that actually lead to success you know
winning
and finally number five an economy that
promotes innovation
so that we can produce weapons and
technology that are unmatched by any
adversary and that won't be stolen by
them five minutes after we invent them
now for decades the u.s establishment
and its supporters in the media have
sought to tear down every one of these
props to our greatness
they don't want the united states to
have a strong industrial base they want
us to be dependent on china
and they look down on the idea of having
an informed patriotic culture
instead they teach young people to hate
this country
and we know they don't want a functional
military because
they encourage woke nonsense every step
of the way
well they certainly don't want effective
generals and admirals they prefer the
type of leadership we saw in afghanistan
and they do not want an innovative
economy they want americans to stay home
smoke dope maybe order from doordash
every now and then
so we're headed for humiliation and
further military defeats if these trends
continue
we lost in iraq we lost in afghanistan
the ccp is on the march throughout asia
things are going to continue until the
united states has an economic system and
military that once again strike fear
into the hearts of our enemies
and that means that the current
establishment must be defeated and that
a new era of patriotic leadership that
actually tries to advance u.s interests
must take its place
joining me now is retired army colonel
kurt schlichter he's also a senior
columnist at town hall and author of
will be back the fallen rise of america
and gordon shang gatestone institute
senior fellow and author of the great
u.s china tech war
kurt let's start with you because more
than anything else the
the u.s is losing its grip on its
superpower status
in part because of the wokification of
our military and the destruction of
patriotic education in our schools do
you think this is being done
on purpose
well laura i i tend to think that people
like the uh
the the reasonable and anticipated
consequences of their action they've
taken the military which was the most
powerful in the world the united states
military and i i was there in the
persian gulf war in 100 hours uh three
american corps annihilated an entire
nation's army it was a uh achievement on
par with anything that caesar hannibal
alexander had done not that anyone
studies history anymore and would know
who those people are
um
and then we kind of gave up and we
haven't had an unequivocal victory of
that level in about 30 years
uh
do do they intend to uh make us weak
what they intend to do is have a
military that is much like the rest of
uh our institutions it's poorly run
that's focused on
uh wokeness that's focused on culture
war that's focused on
uh you know maintaining and expanding
the power of the people who got us into
this mess in the first place so that's
not melissa that's not a military curse
he wants a disaster yeah kurt that's not
a military that's like a faculty lounge
at swarthmore okay
so what we're describing here is this is
not a fighting force
as
it's supposed to be constituted we have
great men and women who are enlisted men
and women and some and some great
leaders
but the people are really running the
show
they have to know it's not working
gordon yesterday china's ambassador to
the u.s
gave his thoughts on how to avoid a cold
war between our two countries watch
no
democracy versus authority terrorism
narrative
no
geopolitical confrontation
no decoupling no supply cut
no armed race
only by
doing so
can we prevent
u.s china relations
from sliding into a new cold war
gordon isn't the translation there don't
question us
it certainly is it's sort of keep on
trading with us keep on supporting our
economy keep on doing all of these
things even though we're killing
americans even though we're stealing
your intellectual property to the tune
of you know hundreds of billions of
dollars a year even though we
maliciously attack your friends and
allies and you know by the way one of
the first things that president biden
did right after he took the oath of
office he actually signed his executive
order on xenophobia which really was the
communist party's playbook this was
straight out of beijing's propaganda
masters and so yes they want to weaken
the united states because that has to be
the only result of this and and so i
have to say you're absolutely right
about that
well kurt also at the same aspen uh
security forum the southcom commander
general laura richardson she spoke up
about china's military buildup watch
this
what are they going through right now
the largest military buildup in history
so one should ask themselves why when
they have this very capable military
are they putting
and trying to
gain access to critical infrastructure
in other countries across the planet
china would like to replace the united
states that is their goal
and they're well on their way to try to
do that she could be my favorite
military leader that we have right now i
mean she spoke she spoke the truth there
about what china's real aims are
well
china is a serious military laura the
american military is no longer serious
when you're saying that your greatest
strategic threats are white nationalism
and climate change
that's a joke our threats are our
enemies it's china it's north korea it's
iran it's russia
real geopolitical threats
not phantoms uh
invented to
to allow our uh you know democrat
leaders to focus on the the
the people they want to gain more power
over and what this does
this
non-serious
approach the military with all the woke
nonsense drives away the traditional
americans the rural and uh suburban
young people who make up the bulk of our
military who who provide the real heart
and soul of it
veterans are telling young veterans are
telling young men and women not to join
and that's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking for me because i love the
army well gordon we heard something from
biden about plans in 10 days talking to
xi watch
expect to talk to president xi
i think i'll be talking to president xi
within the next 10 days
gordon this is a setup to remove the
tariffs that trump put on chinese goods
i fear
and certainly other things as well you
know biden has had these long
conversations with xi jinping and really
what we have not seen though is the
united states imposed costs on china for
conduct which is just completely
unacceptable
and you know biden keeps on issuing
these warnings over ukraine over
intellectual property theft over
whatever and and never does anything
about it so i think that really these
conversations serve china's purposes by
delaying the united states from taking
action um you know this is something
that is is not only a problem in this
administration but in previous ones but
right now it's it's especially
aggravated for aggravated problem for us
no good will come of that conversation
that is my prediction position of
weakness kurt and gordon great to see
you both tonight thanks so much thanks
lauren
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else